je
eh bien bon soir diagonale l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs
nous sommes ce soir en direct de vichy
or je suis avec le grand maître et loire
l'ange concevoir et loi bonsoir
stéphane bonsoir à tous donc spécial
diagonale pendant six jours à vichy avec
donc des placements de matériels humains
et techniques importants oui alors toute
l'équipe de diagonale et ici à vichy
accompagné de deux donc un réalisateur
un ingé son beaucoup de matériel tout ça
pour vous faire vivre les moments les
plus forts de ce grand tournoi de cet
événement national qui est donc le
championnat de france d'échecs 2000
championnat du millénaire j'aime plein
du millénaire championnat très
importants on va évidemment henry
revenir toute la semaine alors je
rappelle que haut à la vidéo on à
jean-françois paris et aux sons jérôme
ardouin qui ont amené donc tout un
matériel important donc pour faire
suivre en direct de vichy donc c'est la
première fois qu'on vient dire est aussi
long et loi sur un tournoi on a fait
donc les retransmissions de grand prix
sur deux ou trois jours mais là c'est
six jours de déplacement c'est pas
évident oui ils savent être un peu
différent de ce qu'on a déjà fait
puisque normalement on fait des parties
en direct là on aura les joueurs qui
viendront nous commenter leur parti
commenter les événements et veulent
évidemment ouvert à toutes les
évolutions du classement on verra qui
est en tête pour l'instant il ya donc
etienne bacrot qui en difficulté
puisqu'il n'est pas en tête il n'est que
troisième enfin on va y revenir de toute
façon est un très beau plateau cette
année au national et je pense qu'on va
accueillir quelqu'un qui va nous en
parler avec avec beaucoup de
beaucoup de talent beaucoup talent on va
évidemment parler donc de en premier
lieu de comment se place nationale
comment ça se déroule comment on peut
jouer ce national son historique aussi
avec le rien moins que l'organisateur en
chef de cet événement l'a déjà reçu sur
des monnaies les lois c'est le président
de la fédération française monsieur
loubatières merci monsieur le bayern ou
nous rejoindre
donc jean claud battières président la
fédération qui va nous parler maintenant
de ce national avec toutes les les
arcanes de l'organisation de cet
événement leur bonsoir jean claude
bonsoir alors comment ça se passe au
national donc on l'a on a ri faut le
rappeler on arrive en milieu en fait du
tournoi puisque dans la première semaine
s'est déroulée oui donc le national
c'est d'abord ce les 16 meilleurs
joueurs français
à une exception près et il y avait au
départ de groupe de huit joueurs dans
chacun des groupes
c'est un tournoi tout auront tous les
joueurs se rencontrent et puis au bout
des sept rondes
les quatre premiers de chacun des
groupes se retrouvent en poule haute
donc on est maintenant aux premiers
bilans et vont commencer les parties
capitale pour le titre alors aujourd'hui
c'est un jour de repos donc tous les
joueurs de tous les tournois donc il ya
plusieurs tournants d'en parler
puisqu'on va présenter un peu ce
national ya beaucoup plus de monde ici
présents puisque je crois qu'il ya près
de 1000 joueurs tout au moins confondues
il ya en fait exactement 9 144 joueurs
c'est le deuxième meilleur score de
l'histoire deux premiers sets et mille
neuf était lui le troisième score
c'était 891 à nantes en 93 donc c'est un
excellent score au niveau de la quantité
des joueurs et puis c'est le record
absolu au niveau de la force
c'est le plus fort national de tous les
temps les lots moyen supérieur de 1500
c'est aussi le plus fort tournoi féminin
de tous les temps les lots moyen
supérieur à 2200 c'est la plus forte
accession de tous les temps
de grands maîtres dans l'accession et 17
mètres internationaux donc ça fait rêver
d'avoir un tournoi réserve de cette
qualité et puis bon l'open a loupé de
santé sont aussi très fort donc c'est
vraiment le tournoi de l'ain du
millénaire certainement on va parler
d'abord on va présenter les tous les
tournois on va parler d'abord du tournoi
phare c'est évidemment le national donc
seize joueurs peut-être on peut les
citer
l'unicité toussaint ils ont cédé leurs
joueurs français dans que sont là je
crois que les tournois étaient organisés
de façon à ce que le spectacle soit le
plus depuis fort possible ça veut dire
que les appariements été orientés et
donc dans la septième ronde
on les deux meilleurs joueurs de chaque
poule se rencontrer donc on avait d'une
part christian bauer qui jouait contre
dorfman donc la partie est nuls et puis
la deuxième dans l'autre groupe
etienne bacrot qui était en tête
rencontré jean-marc degraeve et l'a donc
surprise de ce tournoi
etienne bacrot a été battu par jean-marc
de veuves donc c'est une surprise mais
jean-marc de grève avec les blancs il
est très fort on sait et pour la petite
histoire c'est la deuxième fois que
cette mésaventure arrive à etienne
bacrot puisque l'an passé il avait
également perdu la dernière partie de la
phase préliminaire
alors on va on va revenir sur la liste
de ces de tous et de tous ces joueurs à
noter que tout à l'heure on va recevoir
chômage de grave à 21h30
accompagné de laurent guitare et lee et
à 22h robert fontaine et christian bauer
viendront aussi commenté leur parti donc
je suppose que jean-marc degraeve
augmentera sa victoire contre les tubes
à croquer tant qu un moment important de
ce tournoi alors les joueurs d'abord
dans la poule a recommencé dans
l'alphabet on va retrouver alors quand
aux chars qui fait un excellent tournoi
risque actuellement il est en tête
enfin il a fini en tête de sa poule donc
c'est ça avec 55 points sur cette hausse
est possible
oui on aura gagné ses trois premières
parties donc avec un peu de chance
puisqu'il a gagné une partie quand igor
hnatow dans laquelle il était
complètement foutu mais enfin bon ça
fait partie du jeu et ensuite il a
assuré donc il a fait des nuls
uniquement des nuls et des nuls souvent
rapides alors il est il se pose quand
même maintenant candidat sérieux au
titre puisqu'il est en tête et c'est un
joueur qui est très difficile à battre
non mais qui fait des nuls eu assez
souvent quand il est en difficulté il
arrive à tenir
voilà un tout à fait alors donc arnaud
hauchard igor nataf qui pour la première
fois fait nationale je crois c'est la
première fois qu'il joue le tournoi
ouais oui tout à fait igor ne voulait
pas jouer cette année bon j'ai réussi à
les convaincre mais je crois que une
année très près quand on a parlé cet
après midi en fait on sait que c'est un
joueur extrêmement talentueux
et puis c'est un joueur lui qui joue
c'est parti à funky qui croient je crois
qu'il est habité par les échecs qui
donne une énergie colossale
donc il devait dans ce national il y est
et puis sans début a été un peu
difficile notamment il a perdu la partie
contre un nouveau char et puis bon il a
encore remporté une victoire décisive
contre
jean-marc de grève qui l'a remis en
selle et à la dernière ont déjoué contre
marc siano
alors ce match a été passionnant parce
que les deux joueurs se rencontrer et il
fallait absolument que marc siano gagne
sinon ils allaient pas en poule finale
et la table lui devait faire nul donc on
a une partie et qui a été théorie que
jusqu'au 26e coup c'était la partie la
défense avenir qui connaissent les coups
c'est ça c'était exactement la
reproduction de la partie au téléphone
jusqu'au 25e coup ça s'est joué en une
minute
les 25 premiers coups à une minute donc
envoyé le temps puisque avec le système
fischer le temps de mon envoyé le temps
des deux jacky qui augmente et c'était
assez intéressant
et puis très rapidement en fait la taf
se trouve être mal très mal et lutter
pour la lune nullité il a trouvé des
ressources et à un moment donné mais il
a fallu il a fallu pour marc siano
prendre des risques ou alors c'était nul
ou alors il prenait des risques il est
rentré dans un réseau de maths et igor
nataf lamater donc une partie très
tendue donc entre ouïgours nataf et
marciano qui a décidé finalement de la
qualification de nataf pour la
bouillotte tout à fait six heures de jeu
il faut pour la petite histoire il faut
dire que david marciano qui est un
joueur solide avait fait six parties
nulles avant et donc la septième par
contre il s'était encore nul mais il a
dû se suicider pour tenter de se
qualifier donc l'eau réduit si de gagner
avant sa 8ème heymans était c'est pas
exactement son style alors ensuite je
fais dans l'ordre de la poule a on
trouve évidemment la star des échecs
français actuel
être avec joël lautier qui est etienne
bacrot le champion de france en titre
donc il joue pour garder son titre donc
etienne bacrot qui est là qui fait un
bon tournoi finalement mais ils vont ils
se qualifient évidemment enfin
évidemment en tout cas c'était supposé
au départ qualifie avec 4 points et demi
donc il est qu un demi point des
premiers finalement il n'est pas loin et
il n'a perdu qu'une partie donc on en a
parlé contre jean-marc degraeve donc à
suivre de près évidemment la prestation
détiennent dans la poule haute
ensuite jean marc degraeve donc qu'ils
se qualifient là on a les quatre
premiers de cette poule a et ensuite
donc on va trouver dans marciano qui a
raté donc finalement sa qualification
dans la partie contre guingamp nat à
fond venant parler et loire au linge
notre commentateur qui fait le tournoi
alors est-ce que c'est pas dur pour lui
peut-être à votre avis la de wii en a
trouvé eloi un petit peu trop pacifiste
c'est clair peut-être qu'il pensait à
autre chose et donc en particulier le
dernier jeu et jouer avec les blancs
contre arnaud hauchard est bon il est il
n'a connu une rapide nullité n'est ce
pas alors que un joueur genre de
compétitions de haut niveau
pleinement genre de compétition de haut
niveau se seraient battus pour se
qualifier
bon vous dire qu'il doit effectivement
pense un peu à diagonale à canal web ça
lui prend un peu évidemment de son
énergie et donc il a réussi quand même
une bonne prestation fils un peu en
dessous de son de son niveau puisqu'il
est une fée une performance enfin
dessous de son niveau et l'eau ensuite
on trouve d'arcoa nietzsche qui avait
fait un très bon championnat la dernière
il nous semble qu'il est arrivé en demi
finale je crois en d'arcole l'année
passée avait gagné sans son groupe avec
six points sur 7 et une performance de
crois que c'était 2816 ce qui est pas
mal et l'estonie si ce dernier
malheureusement il a
on a eu beaucoup de mal à entrer dans le
tournoi il a perdu sa première partie et
ensuite il n'a jamais pu revenir et on
fait on trouve un joueur dont qui est là
qui n'est pas titre est donc là il faut
entendre parler on va y revenir tout à
l'heure c'est laurent guidarini alors
comment un joueur non titré peut-il
jouer nationale alors bon c'est quand
même beau joueur assez fort puisqu'il à
2300 points elo a à peu près un peu
moins est bon ils terminent derniers
m'ont mais sans être ridicule puisqu'il
fait une perf au niveau de son lots à
2300 points dernier cette poule
comment ce joueur se retrouve dans
nationale et bien c'est aussi un des
intérêts de la formule cette formule est
ouverte
en fait les joueurs sont qualifiés par
leur part leurs résultats des années
précédentes les deux précédents
champions les meilleurs lots les grands
maîtres et il ya quand même deux places
qui sont réservés aux vainqueurs de
l'accession de l'année précédente
donc il ya un tournoi qui s'appelle
l'autre mon accession et qui permet aux
deux premiers d'être qualifié pour
l'année suivante
voilà c'est un tournoi qui est très fort
l'année passée il était déjà très fort
d'ailleurs puisqu'il y avait l'année
passée un grand maître et 11 mètres
internationaux il était très fort mais
ce grand maître et séances de maîtres
internationaux ont été battus par deux
jeunes joueurs lors laurent guide alité
leurs rangs le guida r&d qui n'est pas à
titrer mais qui qui a gagné le tournoi
avec guillaume vallet et tous les deux
sont deux jeunes joueurs pour qu'ils
sont très talentueux qui ont battu les m
donc laurent guidarini dans cette poule
a donc vainqueur de l'accession de
l'année dernière donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils jouent le championnat par noter
que cette année on l'avait dit le
tournant accession est très fort et il
ya beaucoup plus de m d'autant plus que
les années d'un peu gras m et 17 mètres
internationaux ces faibles dont
d'ailleurs
jean-luc chavanon pas fait la une je
crois du magazine de la fédération a
tout à fait qui a réalisé une énorme
dont aussi jean-luc serait quatre fois
champion de france
markstrom en trois fois champion de
france nicolas giffard deux fois
champion de france et lui ross champion
de france donc c'est 4 7 et de 9 et un
10 10 dix titres de champion de france
qui sont dans l'accession et des
champions de france assez récent ce qui
prouve le renouvellement très fort des
échecs français
oui donc parce que les anciens champions
doivent se qualifier maintenant c'est de
plus en plus du aurait dû y avoir des
dérogations pour les quand même pour les
pour les institutions pas de sénateur
les fédérations il faut gagner sa place
sur l'échiquier
alors on passe mais tellement groupe b
on a présenté les joueurs du groupe a
avec alors c'est aussi un espoir on l'a
on va retrouver deux espoirs importants
aux deux premières places des jeux de
france et actuel puisque on a le le
français christian bauer qui était le
seul français qualifié aux championnats
du monde de las vegas il avait gagné sa
place le seul français à avoir gagné sa
place je crois que joël lautier au site
est qualifié mais quoi ça sert au départ
ça des gens donc christian bauer qui
termine aussi avec comme meurent nos
chars avec cinq points sur 7 dont qui
fait un très bon tournoi avec une
performance à plus de deux mille six
cent soixante deux mille six cent
soixante trois points exactement de
performance
c'est un très bon début de tournoi
christian est très fort toute façon il
se place un petit peu en favori
puisqu'il est un premier ex-aequo avec
arnaud hauchard mais il a progressé
énormément donc il a joué récemment des
tournois comme l'open de new york où il
a rencontré beaucoup de grands maîtres
au dessus de 2600 en gagnant en faisant
nul
il a joué les championnats d'europe
individuels où il a joué presque à
chaque ronde des joueurs au dessus de
1600 il n'a pas perdu une partie
donc il a vraiment progressé énormément
est ici dans ce tournoi il a montré ses
qualités vont ces qualités sont des
qualités de battant est accrocheur je
veux dire on n'a jamais gagné comme
christian il faut fonds faut se battre
jusqu'au bout
il a été en particulier très mal comme
dans deux parties contre freyssinet et
contre va il sert et il a sauvé des deux
fois le demi point or vous ne quittez
pas parce qu'à 22h avec christian bauer
lui même viendra sur le plateau
et commentera une de ces parties où
plusieurs de ces partis on verra bien le
temps qu'on aura donc en direct et en
vidéo christian bauer va commenter ses
sept premières parties les plus
intéressantes en deuxième on trouve
aussi un espoir important des échecs
français c'est laurent frayssinet qui
qui est maître international on sait
avec arnaud hauchard qui aussi mais
bardot va être grand maître bientôt oui
laurent aussi donc laurent frayssinet
qui est un jeune joueur qui à peu près
de l'âge de etienne bacrot je crois un
an plus un an de plus oui et qui a un
très bon pote de progression et laurent
en fait vider un petit peu quand même
déçu parce que il a fait un excellent
tournoi mais il a gaffé et de gaffer
dans sa partie contre manuela peas est
là et il a perdu en fait de perdre une
pièce alain kouck donc c'est un peu
incroyable et évidemment c'est demi
point où un point entier ce aliments qui
pourraient être en tête ou un demi point
et ça compte beaucoup
sinon il avait joué très bien non qu'il
a fait nul contre dorfman dans une
partie où il a aussi il a montré
beaucoup de ressources parce qu'il était
en difficulté et il a réussi à sauver le
demi point
et puis il a montré beaucoup de choses
je crois qu'il est très fort lui c'est
un des candidats sérieux au titre
mais il a un point de moins que
christian bauer aujourd'hui voilà donc
laurent frayssinet à surveiller de près
aussi mais évidemment il a besoin d'un
point du leader ça va être plus dur mais
il est toujours là et on va retrouver un
troisième à ex-aequo d'onction 3
ex-aequo avec quatre points dans ce
groupe b on retrouve et yossi dorfman
alors dorfman c'est un joueur dont qui
viennent des pays de l'est c'était
l'ancien entraîneur de garry kasparov
tout il a été champion de france il ya
deux ou trois ans de méribel en 98 voilà
c'est ça donc c'est un des joueurs
qu'ils relèvent le niveau des élèves
français par son niveau intrinsèque déjà
par sa propre force de jeu et aussi
parce qu'il donne des cours il a donné
beaucoup de cours et notamment aussi
etienne bacrot mobilité son entraîneur
oui il a été l'entraîneur détiennent
macro il a fait certainement beaucoup de
bien il a aussi et entraîner l'équipe de
france avant les olympiades de novi sad
80 92
et puis il entraîne beaucoup de joueurs
c'est d'un entraîneur très très fort
donc il a une compréhension des échecs
très grande mais les échecs sont un
sport en espagne nous savons depuis un
certain temps donc en tant que joueur il
y manque 7 gré si vite et cette
combativité et il a réussi il a fait six
parties nulles ici et gagner une seule
partie contre guillaume valin avec une
jolie partie et notamment un coup
cavaliers des quatre petites bombes
qu'il faut voir l'aspect relationnel
peut-être peut-être eloi tu peux nous
préparer pour toute à l'heure cette
partie donc dormir contre eux contre
vannes 1 peut-être jeu palois si tu
m'entends
pour vous préparer la partie des
plaintes contre vannes 1 1 où il ya un
coup qu'avec des quatre comme peut-être
pouvoir commenter à la fin de ce tour
d'horizon des joueurs alors on va passer
ensuite au quatrième joueur à la c c'est
un joueur tout à fait atypique je pense
que innovateur c'est l'amateur là ça je
crois que c'est le plus fort amateurs de
france puisqu'il n'est pas professionnel
il est je crois un ingénieur dans une
société qui fait de travail sur le son
je crois et c'est le maître
international jean rené corps qu'elle
largement le niveau d'un grand maître et
qui depuis très longtemps fait parler de
lui la génération de joël lautier mais
il a choisi lui de parfum en faire son
métier
voilà donc ça fait plaisir de le voir à
ce niveau il a joué un très très bon
tournoi
la dernière andy jouer contre happy
c'est là il avait les blancs et apc la
devait gagner donc à pisser l'avait un
peu plus mais jean-rené s'est accroché
c'est une de ses caractéristiques est
souvent il a sauvé des parties lui aussi
aidé à gagner sa place
il vise la norme de grand maître qui lui
donnerait le titre
pour l'instant je crois qu'il doit avoir
une performance de 2560 3,6 me souvenir
exactement oui et donc il va s'il marque
un point sur deux parce qu'il va jouer
contre bacrot il va il est tout proche
de la norme de grand maître
voilà donc jean rony corps qui est donc
un bon position pour faire un nombre de
grands maîtres
alors c'est c'est le dernier qualifié
donc pour cette poule e hôte donc avec
le groupe on va retrouver donc hochart
nataf paquereau deux graves du groupe a
et donc bauer freyssinet dorfman et
corps du groupe b et ensuite on va
trouver donc on finit le tour d'horizon
des joueurs du national
le grand maître manuela peas est là qui
est lui aussi de la génération de gens
en écosse
c'est à peu près le même âge et donc il
fait un bon tournoi aussi mais il rate
la qualification d'un demi point
oui donc
une performance un peu supérieure à son
lots c'était un bon tournoi montre ma
peau lui alors ensuite on trouve un
autre joueur des ex pays de l'est
alors quel peut-être un peu baissé
niveau parce qu'ils se consacrent un peu
moins aux échecs actuellement ça fait un
certain taux l'hiver et qui est très
fort très fort il est très fort mais
donc lui c'est un petit peu il a un
style qui n'est pas du tout celui de
iossif d'hormones
c'est un combattant de l'échiquier et là
le fait de ne pas jouer deux tournois de
haut niveau ça le handicap énormément et
donc ici là était un petit peu en
dessous et donc il a perdu une partie
contre guillaume valin qu'il a dès le
début qui lui a enlevé tout espoir alors
ensuite on trouve encore un jeune joueur
alors qu'elle à gildas robert fontaine
il mêlera nationale il est tout jeune
c'est notre champion de france junior
voilà donc il est champion juniors ils
jouent chez les grands en fait tout à
fait laisser centre deuxième nationale
il l'a fait le national 97 à narbonne où
il était déjà championne de france
junior et là il avait énormément
souffert
il avait terminé dernier mais surtout en
ayant des parties très très difficile
par contre dans ce tournoi il sait ou
assez bien comporté et donc il a
nettement progressé en force de je vous
rappelle que robert fontaine avait
disputé un match de blitz contre l'udc
bergez sur diagonale d'ailleurs qu'on
avait retransmis en direct qui est
disponible toujours vous pouvez voir ce
match de blitz entre luc berger
robert fontaine tendues se déroulaient
mois de mai ou juin
donc je j'y pense parce que le maître
luc bergez est justement là je crois
qu'ils jouent l'accession et je
l'accession il est parmi les dix sept
maîtres internationaux de l'accession
qui rêve d'une qualification pour le
national mais en ce moment et pas de
raison et on retrouve donc dernier de
cette poule il fait lui aussi un point
et demi comme comme laurent guitare et
lee c'est le qualifie de l'accession de
l'an dernier donc là aussi un joueur non
titré guillaume vallet donc fait partie
de ces joueurs qui l'on donne la
possibilité de jouer ce national et
tafer donc c'est un an titré mais il est
presque maître international en tout cas
il il a réalisé deux normes de maître
international
la deuxième c'était à bagneux en juillet
et puis à créon
il a fait une performance qui aura
peut-être valeur de de normes de mettre
en fait il lui manque un joueur étranger
puisque pour faire une norme
il faut qu'il y ait un quota minimum de
quatre étrangers sur sur les dix joueurs
et là il en avait que trois donc c'est
pas tout à fait énorme et ça peut passer
donc devant la commission donc il sera
peut-être maître international mais de
toute façon il a le niveau et il va
devenir maître international très vite
il n'y a pas de problème alors voilà
donc on a fait le tour de l'ensemble des
joueurs du national on va parler un
petit peu donc d autre tournant on a
parlé de l'accession on appelle un peu
des joueurs de de l'accession donc ce
tournoi qui qualifie pour l'an prochain
pour la nationale on va voir un peu du
national féminin un froid que les
missions d'un film n'a jamais été aussi
fort effectivement il ya plein joueuse
je lui à plus de 2200 points ce qui
n'est pas habituel chez les féminines
puisque en général les meilleures
féminines étaient il ya quelques années
encore à 2000 points
oui donc pour faire progresser le niveau
des échecs féminin français ya plusieurs
méthodes on in par les joueuses qui
progresse d'autre part de jeunes
joueuses qui arrivent
et puis troisièmement il ya une
troisième voie il ya des joueurs qui
épousent des ges des pays de l'est
nous devons y en a un certain nombre qui
deviennent française dont qui a marié le
compte il y à un rose à la demande il y
à marina costagliola il y à marina
roumégous on a quatre joueuses qui ont
été naturalisées françaises après avoir
épousé un français un joueur d'échecs
français et qui font qu'ils font que le
niveau est très relevé
mais surprise dans ce féminin parce que
bon tous les pronostics sont renversés
dès la première ronde mal et les
favorites qui était quand même donc
d'une part maria le compte d'autre part
aux à l'allemand les deux plus forts et
l'eau 2289 plus christine flir équipe de
france deux fois champion de france
les deux dernières années et donc ces
trois étaient en était rapidement battu
et on se retrouve très mal hors course
par contre marina costagliola fait 1 100
votes elle a six points sur six donc
c'était un résultat extraordinaire donc
on voit pas qui va l'arrêter maintenant
en fait deux joueuses les deux joueuses
qui sont derrière
en quatre points et demi il s'agit de
marie ce bug
alors ils se reforment parler parce que
c'est tout un axe c'est là un petit peu
les tienne bon qu'on fait mais on va
dire c'est chez les filles c'est la
fille qui marche le mieux c'est la plus
jeune a été champion de france je crois
chez les garçons est là elle est
championne de france des moins de 14 ans
toutes catégories toute la théorie donc
chez les garçons ont fait
voilà un des fils du levant et puis elle
est championne d'europe des moins de 14
ans donc si un espoir on peut dire c'est
un espion et des faits main de monter le
niveau est d'arriver à un bon niveau là
un très fort niveau de jeu bon il faut
rappeler que dans nationale 1 par
exemple elle a fait nul contre jose
miralles nuls contre laurent frayssinet
en partie qui comptait donc des parties
très importante donc où les grands mais
ne les ont pas fait de cadeau
je crois que si on porte des rapides
elle avait battu eloi et loire lange
alors on va on va faire une petite
interruption parce qu'on a avec nous il
va arriver tout de suite c'est le grand
maître international marc santoro mans
l'autre tu peux venir marque s'il te
plaît champion de france 90 91 et 94
voilà donc bon soir marc aulas peut
prendre un micro alors marsan tourments
tu joue actuellement le tournoi
accession alors comment ça se passe
est-ce que c'est difficile d'essayer de
remonter en fait puisque tu vas essayer
de te qualifier pour le national mais là
c'est la première fois que je vous
tourner l'accession j'ai toujours eu la
chance de voir je voudrais sur langage
et désiré parce que j'avais à l'époque
niveau suffisant quand j'étais très
jeune et je me suis dit tiens on va
faire un challenge va se faire un défi
on va voir si on est capable de gagner
ce tournoi et s'est passé c'est pas
facile parce qu'il faut faire beaucoup
de points il faut faire beaucoup de
points et il faut pas un n'a pas
beaucoup de droit à l'erreur à mâcher
déjà affrontés une fois j'ai perdu une
partie déjà
et là je suis dans un groupe le groupe
de quatre ans et demi sur six es1
quelques joueurs devant et c'est pas
facile mais par quels sont les joueurs
qui dominent nettement accession le
premier ses joueurs au maine qui qui
habite en france quelques années
s'appelle loukou et ensuite ya cinq
joueurs sont toujours issus de qualifier
pour le pôle national je ne pense pas
non il n'a pas la nationalité française
donc il a le droit de jouer parce qu'il
réside en france depuis deux ans il est
lisse il est sur la liste fille dé
france mais par contre il ne peut pas se
qualifier pour le national alors
pourquoi il s'est sûrement là et pas un
autre tournoi plutôt parce que c'est
intéressant de c'est un bon tournoi il
ya des prix intéressants et donc
d'accord donc c'est pas uniquement un
tournoi pour se qualifier pour la grèce
mais aussi par des étrangers
envie de jouer les trouve intéressantes
à sion et étrangers qui sont quand même
assimilé dans la mesure où ils vivent en
france depuis au moins deux ans ils sont
licenciés à la fédération depuis au
moins deux ans et en plus ils sont sur
la liste fille dé france avec le code
france d'accord dont il ya des
restrictions quand même d'accord donc un
accession difficile jean-claude le
bâtiment d etat l'heure il ya beaucoup
de joueurs titrés dans ce tournoi
accession cette année c'est la première
fois qu'il ya autant il ya énormément de
grands maîtres et de mètres et beaucoup
d'anciens champions de france
c'est vrai je pense qu'effectivement le
niveau monte de plus en plus et
effectivement peut-être qu'une autre
europe beaucoup plus de grands maîtres
ans et qui sont obligés de jouer
l'accession dalglish est peut-être pas
ma faim puisque déjà on a presque une
vingtaine de grammes être en
prospecteurs et comme bien que ça se
passe le national il restera donc des
grands maîtres qui se retrouvent sur le
carreau qui devront peut-être jouer
l'accession donc alors quels sont les
joueurs français donc du coup alors
qu'ils peuvent prétendre à se qualifier
pour le national de l'an prochain les
joueurs en tête un français actuellement
il ya un jeune cheval qui a déjà fait
national et jean pierre boudou qui l'a
déjà fait aussi il ya olivier 12 en qui
l'a fait aussi et quelques années et je
crois je sais pas si beaucoup d'autres
joueurs parce qu'il ya pas mal de
joueurs qui ont lâché qu'elle déjà des
points parmi les favoris du tournoi
d'accord alors on va revenir maintenant
donc on a parlé du national féminin avec
donc
marie sebag notamment la petite
française qui fait parler d'elle et puis
que les pronostics sont peu renversé
dans ce championnat il ya aussi il faut
citer anne muller qui a quatre points et
demi et qui donc deuxièmes ex-aequo avec
marie et et aussi donc une surprise
d'accord alors on va parler aussi de
maintenant des autres tournois donc pour
moi que pour les cités parce qu'il ya
c'est un rendez vous donc à la fois très
fort pour le tournoi de importants comme
on vient de le voir l'accession
évidemment qui permet de se qualifier
pour le national le national avec avec
16 joueurs et on va retrouver aussi
d'autres tournois ouverts aux amateurs
qui fait que ici un événement échiquier
où il ya près de 1000 joueurs c'est une
gigantesque kermesse où tout le monde
peut venir et prendre son plaisir
alors quelles sont ces autres tournois
et d'ambition pour il pourrait jouer
finalement l'opéra l'opéra c'est un
tournoi qui est réservé aux joueurs qui
ont entre 1900 et 2000 2005 on a relevé
la barre de l'eau pena qui était à 18
cents l'an passé on l'a relevé parce que
le niveau augmente et qu'ils qualifient
des joueurs pour l'accession les dix
premiers sont qualifiés pour l'accession
et combien de joueurs dans cet open a et
il vient de 160 et 12 joueurs peut-être
ou peut-être même plus
donc en fait le niveau et 218 voilà
après ma fiche
alors après donc ça donc ça c'est le
joueur plus de 2 me de valeur en points
d'eau donc c'est déjà assez fort parce
que je crois que la moyenne des lots
français c'est aux alentours de 1600
points c'est ça on est mais il faut dire
que le championnat
est très fort la moyenne d 944
participants c'est 1875 c'est incroyable
mais il est le 10 mai il faut pas
décourager les gens qui ont un niveau
moindre
on peut on peut jouer dans tous les
tournois là encore le pen bé et puis
l'open c'est alors voilà donc il faut
faut pas avoir peur de venir jouer le
championnat de france
aussi si on dit que c'est trop forte
personne n'ignore alors on met les gens
viennent aussi pour le spectacle
nationale c'est un spectacle on n'a pas
encore parlé mais bon voir les joueurs
sur la scène avec les huit partis qui
sont retransmises en direct ont froid
dès 18h sur l'écran sur les écrans c'est
fabuleux de confronter les amateurs et
puis les grands maîtres marque centre
romain y compris vient de voir et
analyser des parties on va voir ça tout
à l'heure avec la partie dont on a parlé
puis on en verra d'autres avec avec
jean-marc degraeve écrit sans bruit
évidemment on fera des images de ce
national pour montrer évidemment le
spectacle que c'est parce que c'est
évidemment important donc l'oplb
maintenant pour les moines de 2011 des
moins de 2000 tout le monde peut jouer
moins de 2000 donc alors ses réserves au
moins 2000 donc si on a plus de 2000 on
peut pas s'offrir pour ce pour ce moment
là il ya deux cent douze joueurs c'est
pas mal et puis donc là aussi il ya des
joueurs il ya un joueur qui à 2000 il
pourrait faire il aurait pu jouer l'open
a donc puisqu'il ya une fourchette dans
lesquels on a le choix entre l'open à l
open bée mais il a choisi de jouer
l'open b pour la gagner pour le gagner
est ce qu'il est en tête actuellement je
ne vois pas dans les trop de crainte
qu'ils soient en tête n'ont donc il
s'est trouvé avec les plus petits mais
il s'est fait manger ça arrive donc
loupé n'diaye réservée au moins de 2000
et l'eau et enfin l'open c'est réservé
au moins 2700 là aussi un certain nombre
de joueurs comme en 2007 donc l'on peut
dire c'est réservé
on peut dire aux amateurs ouvert aux
amateurs vont tout à fait donc là parce
que moins de 1700 la moyenne des joueurs
d'échecs de clubs ses 1600 points à peu
près oui tout à fait dans beaucoup de
joueurs peuvent participer à tous les
niveaux qui sont là les gens jouent
vraiment aussi pour pour le plaisir marc
tu peux pas jouer l'open c'est vrai
j'aimerais bien jouer l'open c'est j'ai
pas de remplaçant donc voila et après il
ya un tournoi spécial aussi qui est
l'open des vétérans championne de france
des vétérans réservé aux joueurs qui ont
plus de 55 ans au 1er janvier et qui qui
en est un qui a eu un vainqueur unique
depuis trois ans et volodia weissmann
maître international qui qui domine
quand il à 200 points de plus que son
suivant et il a pour l'instant carton
plein dacourt donc mais par contre est
ce qu'il ya des jours de plus de 55 ans
quand ils font le national
directement est ce qu'il ya eu de la
nationale non mais il y en a qui jouent
d'un dans le lot pénale tout cas dans
nos points d'accord donc en tout cas
c'est réservé si on veut jouer alors les
gens de son âge on peut jouer aussi cet
open della guerra pas ressasser la force
d'échecs aussi on peut dire c'est qu'on
peut jouer deux de quatre ans jusqu'à
plus soif
on n'a pas de limites dix ans que la
force de jeu aux échecs dix minutes qui
peu moins vite que dans les autres
sports qu'un c'est un avantage
oui alors on a fait le tour du site
auront alors maintenant on va essayer de
voir justement on a parlé tout à l'heure
de cette partie entre entre you seek
dorfman et et guillaume vallet c'est ça
oui s'est apprécié de voir un petit peu
cette partie à ce que tu l'a suivi marc
chotteau romain cette partie je n'ai pas
suivi je jouais de tournon action donc
je dois quand même la regarder un peu
avec nous puisqu'il paraît qu'il ya un
super coup de noi cité
alors voilà c'est cette partie
qu'on va peut-être déroulé peut-être
eloi relance qui est aux manettes lanouf
est déroulé les coûts des coûts de cette
de cette partie donc c'est une défense
comment ça s'appelle ça c'est west end à
usage unique et le motif de refus
mahdjoub le coup eux 2 4 qui est donc
une surprise puisque c'est habituel dans
cette position normalement on préfère
cavaliers f3 ou vous g3 au fond j'ai 5
enfin principalement fou g5 et le coût
principal e 4 c'est une surprise c'est
très ambitieux ça veut prendre
directement le centre
donc tout le centre ouvre trois pions au
centre qui sont quand même très très
optimiste
cette défense nous invite sur la
commande tic plusieurs fois dans des
diagonales on a eu les occasions on a
commenté plusieurs notamment des fins
joué par anatoli karpov contrat jusqu'en
gare si je me souviens bien
donc c'est une défense très très utilisé
donc dont le butin général marc je crois
que me démentira pas et de contrôler la
case e 4 pour les noirs
ah oui mais oui le four et le pouce et 8
à pellefigue et aux dames et d'un a pour
objet de mettre le fond d'un bcm est de
construire la case de 4 ainsi que le
cavaliere 6 voilà donc le but pour les
noirs ces deux contre cette case et le
fou en b4 cloud lecavalier c3 qui
protègent cette classe aussi donc voilà
l'idée de ce coup l'idée de cette
ouverture donc c'est pour ça que le coût
de 4 est risqué pour les blancs puisque
les noms a priori contrôle bien ce point
alors fou 17 très logique et la iossif
dorfman donc défendu en quatre par le
couffo détroit au 6e coup et laguian
valin je vous prends ces trois sans être
contraints puisque à 3 n'a pas encore
été joué donc d'hommes france et 3 est
interdite puisque le pion aux 4es en
prison qui oscille dorfman reprend du
plan b est là guillaume valanjou des six
bons ici les blancs ont effectivement
pris le centre très fortement donc le
plan des noirs je pense que c'est bloqué
la position par ces 5 ou 5 alors
peut-être que marx en tournant que nous
en dire plus puisqu'il est c'est un
joueur très positionnelle y être est
positionné mais c'est pas vraiment la
spécialité effectivement étant donné que
les noirs ont changé leur fouloir ils
veulent essayer de contrôler classement
avec leurs pions en essayant de bloquer
la structure blanche c2 c3 par exemple
c3 c4 et 3,50 mètres influence est
simple on leur met un peu en hausse eric
effectivement pour rendre donc le fou le
foot dès le foot blanc des blancs un peu
inutile quoi souffrent des trois qui
débuterait canton ses propres pions en
fait simplement voilà alors cavaliers
j'ai eu deux périodes mais même puisque
c'est le sol damas est petit rock les
blancs sortent leurs pièces et
maintenant effectivement les noirs ont
un problème puisqu'ils savent plus trop
quoi faire de leurs droits sur petit
rock qui vont se faire proprement
pulvérisé puisque iossif dorfman aura
joué avec f4 f5 ou f4 5 fu des trois
dames c'est lui enfin les deux fois
braqués sur le roi dont guillaume valin
choisi jouer à gran rock mais on va voir
que c'est pas beaucoup mieux qu'à
laisser six dont grand roque saint roch
du côté donc dame
on va voir ses seins l'europe si le
moins inusité mais qui n'en est pas
moins efficace fou à 3 donc clouage sur
la dame hausse est là comme on peut le
voir effectivement donc la dame le pion
sommes des six ne peut pas bouger
puisque le vous prendrez la dame d'amd
cette f4 iossif prend tout le centre
grand roque des 5 voilà c'est le couple
est dans cette position il chasse le
cavalier le cavalier va très logiquement
à 5
et maintenant après fougue et 4 c'est
une catastrophe pour les noirs
puisqu'ils peuvent plus éviter fou prend
cavaliers qui affaiblit complètement la
structure de pions côté grand roc noir
et après ça la défense devient très très
difficiles notamment que le cavaly blanc
aux deux peuvent sauter en t4
probablement
alors donc ça veut dire aussi que si une
fois que les blancs en prendront ce
cavalier à 5 donc que le pion b6 va
reprendre sa mort une colonne pour les
blancs qui est la colonne b une tour
blanche donc pourra se positionner avec
une grosse attaque
sur le fond mme bessette et en plus sur
le roi noir voilà donc ici guillon va
linge ou c5
il y aussi je prends à 5 très logique b
prend à tour avait un don comprend la
colonne b on s'apprête l'impression que
la marque sans tourment que les que les
noirs n'ont pas de contrôle de la
opposés au plan mais le problème du plan
des noirs c'est le problème active leur
tour et je l'aï n'ont pas de d'avenir
pour la reprise n'ont pas la capacité
vraiment d'ouvrir une colonne balises
avaient ils ont juste prendre des cinq
ses premiers singles c'est pas bon pour
eux donc ils ont aucun contre je veux
donc qu'ils sont c'est juste une
question d'hommes et hambourg pour
gagner pour les blancs de caution qu'on
peut noter la différence d'activité
entre la tour b 1 qui contrôle cette
colombe et si on peut montrer ses
recettes à cette colonne déjà merci
excellent les lois et les noirs par
contre n'ont pas l'équivalent puisque
leurs deux tours en des 8 et 11 feed
qu'on le fait remarquer marc soto romans
sont mais finalement derrière leurs
pions et donc ne participe à l'action
pour l'instant le fou b71 +21 et romain
passif est bon nous allons peut-être
passé sur cette partie puisque d'autres
invités attendent quand même d'autres
invités à temps on va peut-être arriver
aux coups que vous les montrer
jean-claude loubatière juste après
puisque les blancs ont joué le coin
c'est fini le 4s qui avait les d4 la
superbe coup 16e coup le fameux 16e
cookies dans ce tournant est critique
puisque
en au char battu djokovic en seize coups
il ya eu plusieurs 16e coup très
critique dans cet endroit et la qualité
des quatre en est un effectivement sur
ces prend des quatre je pense qu'il
suivrait une combinaison alors voici les
noirs prennent le cavalier des 4
qu'est-ce qui se passe donc jean claude
ben c'est ce qui est bien et jouent ces
cinq ce qui s'est passé c'est la fin
pour avoir la bonne affluence évidemment
des filtres et lecavalier dans le camp
adverse je suppose en c6 ou en b 5 et 6
des noirs prennent le cavalier c'est la
partie donc nous dit jean tu le bâtir
donc on peut voir surprend ses cinq c5
et la csn caisse a démoli complètement
le camp noir c'est à dire trop prompts à
6 en fait ça me laisse reprend 1,6 et
après ah oui il ya des noirs et charge
les noirs sont obligés dé changer le
foot est roi et à près d'un mètre en d3
il ya menace de maths c'est sarah 6 mars
damas six échecs et mat
il réplique à matt black guillaume
valant essaie de sortir il ajouté mme à
4 mais aussi le dorfman ne laisse pas le
roi s'échapper en dix-sept il joue c5 c6
haoussa ans ferme le roi noir
complètement c'est très beau enferme le
rejoindre effectivement après tour des
u18 pour aller sur la case des huit
damas six échecs au rendez vite et là on
enferme le roi une dernière fois avec 15
points à 7
hélas la menace tour b8 mater est
totalement imparable donc que thief
dorfman une pièce de moins mais une
position quand même gagnante puisque il
a gagné très très jolie partie de dorman
alors je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
télécharger les
parti de tous nationale donc revoir la
partie entièrement à votre rythme avec
les commentaires donc la con mais
d'avoir de jean-claude loubatière et
marc sens purement vous pouvez voir ces
partis en téléchargeant les parties donc
sur le site de la fédération vous alors
à plus de modération
c'est www.sec.gov
elles pointent asso.fr voilà il a on a
toutes les parties télécharger en format
pgn et c'est un format qui est visible
par tous les logiciels du marché que
l'on peut dire et aussi des logiciels
libres en téléchargement gratuit sur
internet
j'étais là mais je vous remercie tous
les deux de nous avoir accompagnés ces
quelques minutes merci à toi et on va
recevoir de nouveaux invités et non des
moindres puisque ces deux joueurs de la
poule donc à du national c'est il me
rejoignent maintenant donc jean-marc
degraeve bonsoir jean marc le grand
maître international jean-marc degraeve
bonsoir et donc laurent guidarini donc
on entendra parler de salaires donc
c'est un des joueurs qui s'est qualifiée
pour nationale en gagnant de l'accession
de l'année dernière mais massa alors
jean marc
on a parlé de tout à l'heure parce que
tu as fait une très bonne performance
hier tu as battu le champion de france
oui bon
je devais presque gagné mais bon s'il
faisait nul j'étais en fait peut-être un
match des partages avec david marsais
nous donc je devais à tout prix gagner
mon jeu joue un début que je connaissais
très bien j'avais les blancs ça a bien
marché
la hiérarchie est un peu mauvaise parce
que c'est pas c'est pas tous les jours
que dieu macro par une partie un peu la
fin si oui l'année passée il a perdu la
dernière aussi la septième est donc
peut-être qui perd toutes les sections
monde je souhaiterais qu'on s'était
arrangé pour jouer la 7e voilà alors
laurent avec d'arménie baisse et c'est
intéressant d'avoir un joueur comme ça
qu'il est l'accession d'adhérents quel
effet ça fait de jouer entre guillemets
parmi les grands on peut dire ça mais
d'abord c'est vachement impressionnant
quoi parce que enfin je n'en ai pas
l'habitude de jouer contre des joueurs
de ce niveau c'est la première fois que
que jon anza aussi fort et puis il faut
dire que la première ronde c'était assez
impressionnant de jouer devant un public
aussi nombreux à quoi donc c'est très
impressionnant ça déstabilise un peu
ouais on a là même qui tremblent un peu
mais bon bout d'un moment après ça va
s'habituer
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on a le sentiment
de progresser il a apprécié cette
première ronde aux joueurs qu'on a
rencontrés ouais enfin c'est clair que
ça tous les jours on apprend et sur
toile analyse j'ai motion d'avoir donc
là d'avoir pris beaucoup de choses on va
rappeler ce que si l'analyse alors
certes les joueurs on
il faut qu'on explique un peu ce qui se
passe les jours après leur parti donc
retrouve dans une salle à côté et
revoient leur parti qui s'explique les
coups qu'ils ont ratées ou qu'ils
auraient voulu la jouer on compare un
petit peu ce qu'on a vu en un cri chi
certains dans la partie et on essaie de
trouver de nouvelles idées ou
d'améliorer celles qu'on a eu pendant la
partie de voir si on peut essayer de
voir à quel endroit on a fait une fois
ci on a perdu ou quelque chose comme ça
et essayer d'améliorer avec soin avec
son adversaire notre jeu alors justement
profité d'avoir deux joueurs du national
encore une fois pour commenter des
partis parce que ça va être très
intéressant
alors jean marc je crois on va essayer
de commenter peut-être votre parti entre
tous les deux donc ça va être
intéressant comme ça d'avoir le la vie
de du vainqueur qui a été donc jean marc
hamy la partie 1 féminine à bon à part
dommage que c'était la partie j'aurais
pu aller
excuse moi donc c'est une partie nulle
qui a duré comme un coût 35 36 56 a fini
par l'échec perpétuelle donc l'échec
perpétuelle qui peut rappeler ce que
c'est jean-marc donc en fait il lui fait
échec à chaque fois mon roi mon juana ne
peut pas il est obligé de bouger sur la
même case en fait on répète on obligé de
répéter plusieurs fois la même position
qu'en donc on va on va voir cette partie
donc entre jean-marc degraeve et
nombreux candidats y donc pas gagné mais
nulle part dont une partie
donc laurent a réussi à faire trois
parties nulles sur les sur les toutes
les parties qui t'ont poser c'est si
difficile d'approcher des points ses
joueurs ouais ouais très difficile à
chaque fois l'objet de de m'accrocher
vraiment de faire la partie de ma vie
tous les jours il faut répéter ça et
c'est un moment très difficile glace à
chantilly oui oui en fait je pense
qu'elle est allée assez intéressante à
regarder
voilà cette partie on voit tout de suite
notre jeu manque de travail qui dure
donc 35 ou donc on va essayer de
commenter les goûts et l'ouverture pour
les gens qui nous écoutent c'est
intéressant alors si on peut commencer à
voir les premiers coups oui alors on
peut on peut commencer donc jean-marc
degraeve avec les blancs jouent à 4
comme d'habitude je dirais puisqu'il
joue pratiquement exclusivement secoue
ses cinq cavaliers f3 des six alors ça
tout de suite en de condensats c'est une
défense sicilienne un pas mais oui c'est
une défense s il n est bon après des six
normalement on tourne peut-être vers une
âge d'or ce que je vaux kasparov
d'ailleurs ce que je vous kasparov alors
on va voir
alors voyons ça d4 et la kabylie et 6 un
peu atypique normalement on prend des
caps d'abord on élimine tout de suite
alors merci donc c'est alors c'est
atypique c'est intéressant parce qu'on a
le rang avec nous oui pourquoi ces coups
d'abord en fait habituellement jamin que
je vous ces trois opus et 4 d'ailleurs
il ya un an ou deux mais je lui fous c4
est là comme il a joué des cats j'ai
pensé qu'ils voulaient jouer autre chose
qui s'était préparé et j'ai imaginé
qu'ils voulaient jouer dans le rang des
quatre sur ces 30 des 4 et ensuite je
veux une ligne avec ses 4 et comme
j'aimais pas vraiment ça je voulais
éviter ça je joue d'abord cavalli m6 et
maintenant si je joue cavalier c3 le
pion ces deux points pu venir en c4 et
donc j'ai réussi plus ou moins évité sa
préparation je pense
voilà l'explication
c'est bon on attend donc la donc
effectivement jean marc jukka et c3 pour
protéger plus hauts cadres si le couple
naturel jean-marc oui on peut on peut
aussi prendre en c5 alors puis on prend
des cas ensuite d'emprunter 4 quand même
alors dans tout ça c'était le livre que
tu voulais vite je voulais éviter la
ligne avec des enfants des quatre essais
4 donc là il a un cavalier en c3 je
trouve ça un petit peu moins désagréable
quoi d'accord donc là la dame est
exposée quand même au pied c'est à dire
puisqu'on le coup cavalli c6 va être
obligé de la chasse et ça va gagner un
temps pour les noirs oui mais je voulais
pas jouer tout de suite parce que je
pense que jean marc parent a répondu fou
b5 et je préférerais éviter un jean
d'abord fou 17 éviter le clouage avec
roubaix sont d'accord donc là leur
pardon et loi nous montre admirablement
ce qui se serait passé
donc la foux 17 donc ensuite l'allée
blanc réplique par on va le voir tout de
suite ou gsm donc ça on rentre c'est des
schémas de la maintenance et un peu
changé parce que mon un âge d'or font
jouer avec à 6 donc bon il est blanc en
plus dans la jungle âge d'enfants jouent
aux cavaliers f3 prend des 4 donc on
leur cavalier f3 en déca tepa la dame
qu'est ce qui est mieux que donc c'est
toujours pareil oui en fait non c'est un
atout une wii ça rien à payer ses six
des nationales alors de 6 dont classe et
on a quand même une structure de
sicilienne avec les noirs la différence
près que il semblerait que l'on ait
perdu beaucoup de temps qu'on parlera
aux heures normales ou de cavaliers
serait déjà en d4 je pense oui c'est le
nom que sa porte donc ici après aussi ce
je pense que les bleus ont perdu un
temps je sais pas jean-marc comment tu
te sens tu es dans cette position mais
en tout cas a priori il semble ok noir
et effet un succès avec cette ouverture
mais j'étais pas très content je vous
donc d'autant que c'est un succès on va
peut-être s'arrêter deux secondes
puisque laurent m c'est donc un succès
de l'ouverture pour les noirs
oui aussi succès en tout cas oui j'avais
je pense plus ou moins deviner un que
j'en m'en voulais jouer avec d'apprendre
des quatre essais 4 et en jouant
cavalier fils d'abord je pense que jouer
dans notre handicap par la suite c'était
pas très pas la meilleure idée peut-être
mais si jean-marc avait préparé ça il
avait peut-être pas regarder d'autres
choses après qu'elle ait mené 4 d'accord
donc là on a vu donc le grand roque de
la part des blues lui paraît logique
puisque le terrain a été déblayée puis
maintenant la tour est bien placé sur
une colonne centrale les autres oui à 6
et maintenant qu'elle va aider 4 donc ça
fait internet de moins c'est pas c'est
pas du tout une bonne opération pour les
blancs a priori et s'il est noir
continue logiquement parfois hausse est
donc position assez tranquille le roi
noir va faire le petit rock et mettre à
l'abri donc ici c'est une c est normal
avec peut-être l'égalité probable pour
les noix donc ça ressemble cette fois
maintenant jamaran âge d'or plutôt une
râleuse heures comme twitter a laissé un
peu connu c'est l'opposition vers un
centre niveau là voici s'était joué à
dix ans qu'une quelquefois dans la nage
de rechange ou plutôt cinq ont des pions
en sept ans u15 donc bon là on a plutôt
joué aussi ce donc on retourne demandé
plus tôt dans des schémas browser on est
de d66 tandis que dans la salle quand
même + 5
une autre différence effectivement c'est
que le cavalier souvent dans la nage
dorff ne va penser 6 mai en 17 et ans et
5 pour attaquer puis en quatre à mettre
la pression sur les cases blanches
enfin le disons qu'on n'a pas encore
sorti lequel et des beats on garde plus
de souplesse son jeune âge d'or
de très fort nous explique tout ça donc
c'est très bien mais si j'apprends je
suis comme vous donc là on est à
cavalier prendre des cartes pour les
noirs et pour l'un et blanc reprennent
le clavier ce qui paraît logique et
damas cinq ans à ségou développement de
la dame oui oui on attaque le fouquet si
tu as un g5 et dans ce style de position
dans la sicilienne généralement les les
rucks deux côtés opposés donc les blancs
ou à essayer d'attaquer sur les droits
et les mains plutôt sur les ailes dame
donc je peux je positionne les ja madame
du gouverneur adjoint
oui on a 5 parce que le pion à doute
assez faible 1 dans le grand roque
c'est le point faible souvent donc mon
cavalier c3 ne peut pas bouger quoi
d'accord dont peut-être les blancs
faudra faire attention à la poussée pcb
4 qui chasserait lecavalier
alors ensuite
donc on va voir la suite dam des deux
donc ici ça mon pour l'instant on n'a
simplement retiré la dame
oui mais mon idée c'était un peu de
jouer donc de protéger de fou g5 d'azur
et sur petit rock de jeu roye b 1
afin de pouvoir menacer cavaliers des
cinq classes et qu'après on voit bien
qu'à valider cinq évidemment la dame des
deux sera en prise mais s'il a d'abord
le prend on prend d'abord le fou 7 avec
l'échec
et ensuite ensuite on reprend la demande
en gagnant une pièce oui tout à fait
donc ça c'est effectivement c'est un des
thèmes cinquième classe ekoué mais bon
la dame est mieux pressants des deux
camps des quatre coins
donc j'en profite un contrat dont il
souffre
cette dame ça fait deux ans a fait une
deuxième fois qu'elle 24 qu'elle
reviendrait donc l'impression qu'il perd
du temps elle perd du temps mais c'est
la vie pour ses victoires ses huit de la
part des non ça c'est toujours dans
l'idée d'attaquer de tôle et le drame
oui toujours oui et on garde toujours à
l'esprit un des thèmes classiques de la
cécilienne qui est de sacrifier la
qualité de ces trois pour pouvoir
affaiblir leur rock adverse et là en
l'occurrence en même temps on voit
qu'une fois que le cavaliere a été pris
on pourra jouer est en train de et
continue l attaque d'accord donc donc
c'est très logique
et pourquoi retarder l'europe est ce
qu'on se dit toujours il faut roque
évite aux échecs
pourquoi alors en fait j'ai su tirer
profit du fait que jean marc avait perdu
plusieurs temps comme on vient de le
dire avec saddam notamment et donc je me
disais que peut-être qu'il fallait que
je lance une attaque très rapidement un
plan que lui n'avait pas encore commencé
la sienne et l'europe sur une perte de
temps but de cette attaque
une perte de temps et peut-être comment
voyait pour l'instant plus d'insécurité
au centre que s'il était un g8
d'accord on peut remarquer ici que les
noirs ou une menace immédiate même tout
reprend ses 3 est vraiment très fort
puisque d'emprunt est interdite à cause
de dames profonde et cinq échecs mais
qui voudrait reprendre du cube et après
d'un point à 2 les noirs serait beaucoup
mieux une variante signalé par luc
bergez tout de suite il ya une menace
dit aussi pour les noirs tout reprend
6,3 et cavaliers pro 1 4 gagnent tout de
suite sur monastir france et 3 p prend
ces trois cavaliers prend 4 gagne
immédiatement donc une menace vraiment
très direct très trop semaine je vous
invite à analyser
devant la menace des noirs tout reprend
cavaliers ces trois suivantes ullmann de
cavaliers prend 4 c'est ça oui c'est ça
et après fou projet 5 et je gagne adam
d2 avec leur ont assez inquiets qui est
cloué voilà c'est clair j'espère encore
donc voilà à ce cadre pour les pour les
blancs 6 alors ça donc les les noirs
demande au fond ce qui va faire c'est ça
voilà j'ai réfléchi assez longtemps on
secoue ce que je comptais jouer des cinq
tout de suite mais le fond en jeu 5
était assez gênant dans plusieurs
variantes
donc j'ai décidé d'abord de le chasser
et ensuite seulement de jouer des cinq
pour essayer d'ouvrir le jeu et attaquer
directement à l'endroit de jorna sa
contre attaque de tous les côtés donc le
fou revient sur la case de trois
préfèrent se reculer alors esquivé
d'autres solutions jean-marc voteront
non parce qu'on va pas donner le goût de
cases noires préfou praxis ou praxis le
fouquet noire serait terrible mon
cavalier c3 il devait s'attaquer enfin
ça serait pas possible
fouere 4 le fou ne sert à rien prêté 5
le fond n'est-ce 4 ne servirait
strictement rien à eux trois ils
contrôlent et 15 b si c'est cassé 5
quelquefois ça peut être utile voilà
explications jamin de grâce à ce coup
fourré 3 alors ensuite donc les noirs
suivent par des scènes alors ça c'est
lors des 5
c'est souvent on le dit se croit dans
l'est dans les livres pas mal et puis on
en a parlé d'un diagonale aussi
plusieurs fois ci dans la sicilienne
coup libérateur voilà et là en
l'occurrence dans libère la diagonale
pour le fouquet place et en recettes et
en menacent directement fou b4 qui
permettra par exemple un sacrifice de
qualité en c3 mais prend ses trois faut
prendre ces trois et
les noms vont bientôt matin laurent
blanc oui disons plutôt que ces menaces
rapinier une pièce puisque effectivement
à preuve les quatre français trois
gagnerait gagnerait tout simplement donc
voilà l'explication donc en tout cas
d'éden donc c'est si du coup une grosse
menace pour toi j'ai en arc à ce niveau
là il faut faire attention à fort bêta
oui il faut faire très attention mais de
façon je peux pas l'empêcher donc il
faut essayer de contrecarrer se plaint
parce qu'à ce moment là tu as peur de
perdre le contrôle de la partie est ce
que c'est ce que ça t'est venue à
l'esprit
nous sommes est venu un peu un esprit
bon jeu mais j'ai vu que j'avais analysé
quand même un peu des 5 parce que bon
c'est le coup libérateur donc on sait
qu'on comprend 100 premiers mois j'avais
vu que c'était compliqué mais bon si
j'aime bien les parties compliquée
compte donc c'était une partie
intéressante donc serein quand même dans
la difficulté
serein mais pas à 100% tranquillement
d'accord donc la cfu en fait hein c'est
le moment la partie qui est très chaud
alors on a bien compris que les deux
joueurs entendus donc le coup eux 5 qui
cherchent à bloquer peut-être la
position c'est ça je cherche à bloquer
mes gros j'attaque le cavalier 5 et j'ai
joué en fait tu fous des quatre qui
protégera moncava dc3 bon à la ligne est
d'accord on fixe un peu le centre et
puis on va essayer de contrôler ses
tables et ses 3 qui a ciblé des noirs
puisque vous [ __ ] des quatre menaces
oui le cabba tf6 n'a pas beaucoup de
cases alors la fonte des glaces et alors
ça c'est joli feu contre un faux faux
faux commandes et ça c'est un joli coup
puisque tu sacrifies ton clavier 6 à moi
je veux moi j'ai envie de prendre le
cavalier de tout de suite puis on prend
cavaliers oui en fait c'est pas tout à
fait un sacrifice parce que je peux
jouer pour prendre ces trois ans
maintenant et je manque peut pas
reprendre la tour sous peine de mettre
assez rapide après faut prendre ces
trois et damas trois échecs donc surpris
au point cavaliers tout reprend ses 3 si
tu reprends alors pas de la dame
évidemment parce que tu perdais la dame
nommé les leviers en trois il y aurait
maintenant faut prendre ces trois faut
penser trop latham et attaquer les îles
si la dame bouge on joue demain trois
échecs robien et maintenant dmb demain
voilà donc c'est une attaque de maths
donc il faut faire très attention mais
j'ai un homme prend quand même le
cavalier c'est ça non mais non ça c'est
la variante peu de montreuil doigt c'est
là par un trou de montrer loi voilà donc
qui on prend 1,6 il y aurait tout
prendre cavaliers par exemple sur food
et 4 ou comprend g7 d'abord
intermédiaire tour g8
alors non là on a des problèmes parce
qu'ils voient là puis d'emprunter cet or
j'évite donc j'invite par exemple sur un
coup comme roy b1 les noirs jouent tour
à 3 to à 3
ah oui on s'attaque la dame d2 et la
tour va prendre le pion à dos et ça et
je me ferme à thé et à l'aller tu veux
te faire maintenant il faut fait faut
éviter cette variante
il faut éviter de se faire mater je
pense oui alors on va on va revenir
évidemment on va revenir à cette
position très intéressante donc ça
c'était et loire lange qui nous a montré
les coûts donc de possibles
donc après le 5 fu p 4 il faut que voilà
jean-marc à jouer au foot des quatre qui
consolidait en fait bon ça arrive
souvent dans cette sicilienne c'est
qu'on sacrifie à 2 contre les changes du
foot cases noires et comme ça les noirs
ont nettement moins d'attac
oui parce que les normes vont quand même
pouvoir pour le pion à 2 faut prendre
cavaliers et après d'apprendre la dame 3
d'eau menaçant d'amarrer amat on va voir
que ce que justement c'est un jour où
laurent mais il a joué la variante faut
prendre cavaliers fukang cavaliers d'un
prend à deux et attention puisqu'il ya
menace
dahmane
attention donc je peux pas prendre ma
cabane f6 donc si on prenait le travail
aussi ça serait matin donc dam des
cartes ça sert à donner de l'air au roi
si damas un chèque roi des deux et on
s'échappe voilà donc cavalier g8
maintenant donc les noirs puent le
recueil lorsqu'elle n'est pas une
meilleure case pour ce cavalier parce
qu'en général on n'aime pas trop mettre
ses pièces sur l'horizon n'est pas la
seule case qui restait c'était h5 mais
j'aimais pas trop mettre mon cavalier à
la bande de surtout je pense que j'en
manque serait fait un plaisir d'essayer
de me veulent attraper un joint par
exemple courage 3 et g4 et le cavalier
plus de cases d'accord donc cavalier g8
ça c'est tranquille et ça se dit que le
cavalier va être recyclés par la part de
crs et c6 par exemple et après on peut
éventuellement même faire faire le coach
exact d'accord donc peu 5
alors notre dame du cap pardon comme
j'ai catalans lors sa menace le plonger
cette même en fait jean marc essayer de
tirer profit du fait que mon endroit et
pas très bien développé et il essayait
tout de suite d'avoir dû contre jeu
d'accord donc là les noirs jouent
cavailles hausse est quand même donc là
c'est un sacrifice de pions oui je rends
le pion que j'ai pris un à deux mais
d'un autre côté je vais
je vais active et mes pièces tout de
suite elle est développée d'accord donc
déjà marqué prend donc en fait à chaque
fois un millier de menaces mais on le
fait quand même
c'est sa vie si je joue de la musique 4
et qui joue kallio set je prends g7
sinon je vous nomme g can servir
vraiment d'accord ce n'était pas une
menace dans le vent comme on y allant
d'un match 7
alors pourquoi h7 cette dame est ce
qu'il est bien placé n'a pas tant elles
pourraient pas prendre le pion à 6 ou si
on va me fait avancer parce que la fin
de la partie comme très intéressant
polyvalent voilà la dame h77 importante
parce qu'elle défend ses deux on ne
verra plus tard
alors x 4 maintenant attaque le fiancé 2
justement g4 voilà et si j'avais joué
dame praxis les noirs on aurait pu jouer
tout reprend ses trois mellal a été un
match cette défense et 2 dont il ya pas
mal tant ces deux à oui d'accord parce
qu'après pions c3 à la dame et le four
est attaqué c'est 2 et adam d'accord la
dame h7 protège cette case c'est donc
tout le tout l'idée de jean marc sur ce
qu'on voit là et en plus ce qui a valu
un 7 ne peut pas bouger parce que la
tour g8 est attaqué et oui c'est le
terme les bulldogs frantour g8 avec
échec perdu tourner est donc le travail
et vie c'est donc tout rejet 6 alors
davantage c'est quoi laurent sait que
c'est tout une idée c'est oui
et en même temps je coupe la diagonale
de la dame verser 2 donc avis aux
menaces à nouveau tout reprendre ces
trois quarts les mêmes idées que tout à
l'heure
voilà donc tout l'intérêt on protège la
tour par un pion et donc plus par le
cavalier et ensuite on menace tout
reprendre fou avec menace de maths
donc c'est chaud quand même oui c'est
quand même assez tendu donc fou détroit
s'intéressant genre puis ça protège ces
deux jours il s'approche des chagos
attaque la tourbe à ce moment là je
pense gagner la partie
parce qu'en plus il lui restait très peu
de temps je pensais qu'elle ait craqué
oui ici il semblerait quand même que les
blancs soit somme nettement mieux
puisque le roi blanc va aller en
sécurité sur la caisse des deux est là
les lorrains noir est restée au centre
toute façon dont ça c'est important donc
le temps
tu parlais du temps jean marc donc il
restait pourtant en blanc noir ou noir
pardon il risque au moulin
en fait il doit rester je pense de 30
mètres de trois minutes et une bonne
dizaine de conte donc trois minutes pour
atteindre le 40e coup maintien on est à
quelques ou là à peu près de la partie
je ne sais pas du tout peut-être eloi tu
peux nous dire oui oui je peux le jeu
peut le dire dans nos vingt troisième
coup 33e 23e 33e donc rs10 l'es17
donc on va peut-être avancer donc mais
le temps pour les noirs et très court de
trois minutes pour atteindre le 40e coup
donc il faut aimer comme c'est très
tendu ça c'est difficile de trouver les
bons mots à chaque fois donc ça c'est un
paramètre important du jeu d'échecs de
compétition c'est cette fameuse pendu
alors on va voir ensuite donc tout
reprend ses droits quand même donc là
c'est chou en trois minutes de temps qui
reste voilé et fils dont la première
partie en plus c'était assez stressant
et je décidé de sacrifier la qualité
parce que je pensais pouvoir arriver à
trouver un perpétuel donc le fameux chez
cartier qu'on va voir ma compassion
d'abord dans la partie puisque on en a
parlé tout à l'heure
l'alternative la tour prends ces trois
étaient pas très emballante puisque je
pense qu'il s'agissait de tours j'ai 6
revient en j'évite donc effectivement on
prend ces trois est quasiment forcé
alors voyons voyons la suite alors puis
on prend ces trois grands tours et la t4
alors là c'est un coup c'est un coup
inattendu sacrifice de pire encore en
fait c'est surtout pour libérer la case
des 5 pour le cavalier maintenant que le
cavalier libéré de la défense de la tour
qu'étant g8 il peut participer
pleinement à la tacc d'accord et de
dessins qui comptera notamment la case
c3 et la case de 3 par exemple le jour
adam un échec 3d 2 et mc trois échecs
là c'est un coup libérateur pour cette
pièce pour qu'elle participe à la
technologie d'ailleurs on y arrive bien
prendre des quatre cavaliers t5 et en
plus le contrôle bien les cases noires
ce qui est bien c'est a priori c'est
complémentaire du fou voilà et comme la
dame va plutôt faire des échecs sur les
classements 1 c est quand même assez
utile d'accord donc la dame à schwyz
échec au roi donc le roi 17
alors pourquoi 17 et pas c'est tout
j'avais peur de tomber vite je prends et
mon roi après un échec sur la case des
six étaient obligés d'aller 1-8-7
incertaine in c'était assez gênant
d'accord donc le droit 17
donc là les blancs continuent aussi
laurent harcèlement puisqu'ils jouent
après roy 17 donc las il ya peu les
possibilités qu'on voit en k2 en cadeau
roi hausse est donc à prendre wade cette
dame est fuite
il a les blancs menace le pion f7 mais
je veux notre dame price était de retour
et donc comme un échec contre attaque
des noirs au roi des deux est forcé et
la dame c3 donc là c'est ça il est noir
qu essayer de pourchasser les blancs
voilà deux secondes sur roissy 1 il y
avait peut-être une répétition de coût
entre autres et la foux prend ces deux
voilà en fait je laisse gens manquent
effectuer sa menace d'un prince est aidé
anne frank et 6 parce qu'une fois que la
dame singes ici sur un cavalier f4 échec
qui fait fourchette à voilà donc ça
s'appelle une défense
en direct c'est ça exact donc il ya une
fourchette qui menace qui prendrait la
dame en cas de prise
donc là jean marc à ce moment là tu es
toujours confiant puisque tu tu as le
sentiment de pouvoir tenir la partie non
maintenant j'avais analysé je pensais
que c'était nul quoi j'avais vu qu'il y
avait chez que perpétuel à la fin tu
avais pas vu avant
si je l'avais vu avant mais je pouvais
rien faire d'accord étant laurent tu
l'avais vu avant tout cette combinaison
tu l'avais vu où elle est apparue
finalement après j'avais pensé avant de
jeu tout reprendre ces trois mais comme
comment être du tout alors j'avais très
peu de temps donc je les jouais très
vite un accès payant pour que j'en
trouve rien de gagnant adacore donc en
fait tu ne t'es pas sûr que de cette
combinaison mais je trouve qu'elle
n'avait jamais rien vu de bons bourges
en main mais quand on n'a pas beaucoup
de temps peut jamais être sûr à 100%
d'accord donc ça c'est bien mais ça
montre aussi que l'on voit pas forcément
tous dans une partie mais que
on joue sa chance à fond je pense que
c'était forcément plus d'accord donc on
va voir les coups suivants
donc faut prendre pour iliad am3 échec
donc la roi f1 et la cavalière quatre
ans lorsqu'à vallier est très fort c'est
ça voilà le cavalier continue à
participer à l' attaque avec la dame
souvent c'est la dame et le cavaly si un
couple assez infernal quand on attaque
et la menace d'armes deux échecs 3g un
oedème jeu de matt la menace parce que
vous prendrez un juste avant pertes et
en fait ce qu'on pouvait tenter de
prendre la tour est ce qu on est en
amour il faut prendre pour ça permettait
de récupérer une tour voilà mais il y
avait un homme prend aussi ses chèques
au roi c'est cette dame des six échecs
froid ces 8es fouet f5 mat
ah oui d'accord donc une combinaison de
maths carrément donc là le ca empêcher
cavaliers 4 empêche cette commission
puisse à contrôler la case aussi tout
simplement voilà ça défend aussi donc
c'est super ce cavalier puisqu'il ya la
fois attaquant et défenseur est là il
avait deux fonctions maintenant mon plan
est franc et puis défendu aventin me
prend 1,4 donc là du sacrifice de c'est
un sacrifice pour enfin c'est pas un
sacrifice sinon je suis mat
donc en fait c'est un sacrifice force et
où il c'est pour faire nul parce qu'au
mans en fait jean marc a perdu la dame
quoi d'accord c'est toujours surprenant
comme ça de donner la dame a toujours
peur et j'ai quand même deux tours et
une pièce pour la dame d'accord donc ça
après d'un programme effectivement il
reste le fou ces deux qui est toujours
en prise par le fou g6 et donc
effectivement matériellement même les
blancs ont l'avantagé on peut dire on a
là oui ils sont gagnants citons enfin
matériellement ils sont gagnants
maintenant la position du roi n'est
assez précaire voilà donc c'est là où
laurent on saute sur l'échec perpétuelle
c'est exact donc dans les 3 roger adom
j'ai trois échecs aux f1 d'un mais siii
encore échec et puis c'est une
répétition de position
donc là ça s'appelle échec par virtuel
puisqu'il n'y a pas moyen de d'échapper
aux échecs on va forcément répété la
position au docteur donc c'est une très
jolie partie donc grosso astucieuse de
sueur froide pardon des deux côtés j'ai
l'impression oui moi j'étais en a une
autre refuse donc c'était encore plus
stressant pour la première ronde d'un
nationale c'est assez difficile à vivre
et pourquoi jean marc c'était peut-être
pas évident avec les blancs de faire nul
contre laurent qui a priori ne fait pas
partie des favoris tué vérité de cette
partie oui j'espérais gagner cette
partie c'est sûr c'était bon après on se
rattrape sur les six autres c'est pas
trop grave
non mais vous remercie tous les deux
pour cette brillante analyse j'espère
que vous allez continuer vous continuez
vos exploits puisque donc laurent tu vas
jouer en poule basse comme on dit entre
guillemets mais donc pour la suite de la
compétition et puis par contre jean-marc
toi tu joues pour le titre puisque tu
vas jouer dans la file est grand chez
les grands ont fait c'est de gagner les
deux parties possible voilà donc avec
quatre points tu es à un point des
premiers tout est possible tout est
possible alors jeté dans merci à vous
d'avoir participé on va retrouver
maintenant on parlait des premiers il
est un des premiers de ce championnat
pour l'instant puisque c'est le grand
maître christian bauer qui va nous
rejoindre tout de suite avec accompagné
avec lui par robert fontaine robert
fontaine qui est un des plus jeunes
joueurs de ce national on en a parlé
tout à l'heure avec jean-claude
loubatière alors bonsoir à tous les deux
donc christian bauer bonsoir et donc
repères fontaine en soit robert alors
comment ça se passait tous les deux là
pour pour ce national peut-être d'abord
robert on va réserver christian pour la
suite donc robert fontaine donc c'est la
deuxième fois que tu fais nationale je
crois c'est ça ouais
la première fois c'était à narbonne en
97 donc c'est difficile pour toi il faut
rappeler que tu es champion de france
mais junior donc c'est à dire que tu vas
y est a priori un des plus jeunes de ce
tournoi avec etienne bacrot et laurent
frayssinet ouais donc c'est pas facile d
jouer contre des joueurs qui ont plus
d'expérience et puis tu as a botté un
hello qui fait partie de la deuxième
moitié
je suis dans les plus faibles
théoriquement donc c'est pas facile oui
mais c'est une expérience quand même
c'est intéressante de jauge alors qu'en
france
à noter que tu étais pas qualifié pour
la provoc mais tu fais pas un résultat
mauvais puisque tu fais un résultat en
conformité avec ton classement tu perd
pas de points alloués fois au vu des
parties j'aurais pu espérer quand même
un peu mieux quoi donc je les voyais un
peu de regret des j'ai fait des parties
nulles voire perdante contre christian
où j'aurais pu avoir un demi point voire
un point de plus non mais c'est quoi
donc on en aura sûrement l'occasion de
voir ça tout à l'heure alors christian
bauer alors on a présenté plusieurs
meurtres leur avec que jean-claude
matière thème des joueurs français qui
actuellement marche le mieux
tu as été au championnat de france
championnat du monde pardon de las vegas
c'est un des deux français qui étaient
là bas avec joël lautier ça fait
d'excellents résultats aussi jeu aux
championnats d'europe par équipes c'est
ça il ya l'open de new york
champion d'europe s'était individuel
juillet oui oui donc je fais une perf à
2640 en ne perdant aucune partie et
l'open de new york aussi ça ou c'est un
bon tournoi aussi pourtant oui j'avais
fait six points et demi sur neuf et
c'est pareil j'avais fait une perf est
au dessus de 2006 soit vous êtes 2006
alors faut rappeler ton classement
actuellement ses 2500 62 points ce qui
est pas mal du tout ces projets 2006
savoir qu'aujourd'hui aux échecs si on a
plus de 1600 ou 2006 on est dans les 100
meilleurs joueurs du monde donc tu
t'approches un petit peu de cette barre
importante parce que s'il n'y a pas
beaucoup de joueurs depuis 2006 mme
ouimet effectivement c'est mon objectif
pour le prochain classement début
janvier d'avoir plus de 2600 et d'entrer
dans les 100 premiers mondiaux
alors tu es professionnel je crois
depuis pas longtemps tu as décidé de
passer le cap c'est ça depuis un an deux
ans de te consacrer à fond aux échecs ça
fait un an et demi exactement
donc depuis septembre à 98 et donc je
travaille un petit peu les échecs et
puis je ne fais pratiquement que ça
d'accord alors en tête de cette poule b
ça a été facile ou difficile hors doit
gagner donc contre robert conte avec
nous contre guillaume valin et contre
eux manuela peas et là c'est ça et 3 et
4 nuls dans l'analyse autres au match
oui en fait j'ai souffert nombre de
parties contre laurent frayssinet et
puis contre un atelier de misère donc
j'ai eu deux fois des positions ainsi
nettement inférieur qu'il a fallu
défendre et contre les autres joueurs
j'ai eu également beaucoup de mal pour
pour gagner contre robert notamment la
première ronde ils auraient dû faire mon
chemin
et puis on mais il a fini par craquer
alors on va essayer justement de voir
puisque vous êtes là tous les deux cette
partie entre vous deux donc entre entre
christian bauer et donc robert fontaine
donc qu'ils avaient des plans dans cette
partie où j'avais les blancs d'accord
donc ses débuts partie tendue c'était à
quelle ronde ce que ça joue aussi la
passion puisque vous avez tout à l'heure
on avait jean marc degraeve contre donc
laurent bidart ali c'était la première
c'était la première et pour vous c'était
votre affrontements
oui un des plus difficiles parce que -
la première en de contrition avec les
noirs c'est quand même pas le meilleur
la meilleure nouvelle quoi la meilleure
nouvelle de rabot sur et je veux
d'autres qui est l'un des plus faibles
donc l'eau a priori tu passes et
christian parmi les plus férus avec
dorfman et freyssinet
alors on voit tout de suite cette partie
là sur notre écran de contrôle
18 c'est quoi 18 c'est le nombre de
minutes c'est ça l'accord ok donc on va
on va donc suivre cette partie dont 18
pour la compte commente yves elle sait
combien de coups 70 90 la fin donc on va
avancer rapidement on va voir d'avoir
l'ouverture est rapidement pour la pour
la nommer c'est toujours intéressant de
connaître d'ouverture donc ça c'est une
défense karo kann je crois c'est ça
voilà donc je jouais d'être des trois au
deuxième coup ce qui est pas très
fréquent ouaip c'est quoi ce choix alors
et on va commander ce choix d'ouverture
après on avancera vers la fin pour voir
le moment intéressant la partie belle
chose était de jouer quelque chose de
ses calmes et d'éviter les préparations
de robert comme c'était une première
ronde je voulais pas embarquer dans
quelque chose de très connu d'accord
être pour toi rouvrir c'était une
surprise cette vue goudé 3 je
m'attendais pas du tout à ça je pense
que tu l'a jamais joué christian donc
mieux bon mais bon c'est pas trop
effrayant plus boîte d'accord on est
tous assez calme après ce qu'il a évité
la préparation quoi donc d'accord ok
donc on va on va suivre cette ouverture
tranquillement
peut-être le et loi bichet pas que tu
peux peut-être commenté aussi rapidement
cette partie oui bah d'un mode 2d
prendre 4 points 4
voilà le feu fin est bloqué ici et
robert jouer 5 je pense que ça a l'air
pas mal pour les noirs puisque puisque
ici ils ont joué ils ont égalisé au
niveau de la structure de pions et
maintenant on s'aventure vers une partie
qui a l'air qui a l'air je dis bien
assez ennuyeuse puisque c'est symétrique
et il se passe apparemment pas grand
chose mais enfin ça doit être plein de
subtilité pour ma part je ne comprends
pas très bien ce genre de position donc
je vais laisser où je vais vous laisser
parler voilà mais je crois que votre
liste un expert de ce type de position
un peu un peu bizarre non oui enfin là
elle n'est pas si bizarre que ça et puis
effectivement elle est très à plat n'y
est a priori pas très intéressante et il
a l'habitude de jouer cette position
celle là exactement non mais enfin je
suis pas spécialement gêné par les
structures un petit peu symétrique
alors quel cas les moments de la partie
peut-être pas dans quelles eaux a fait
dérouler les cours tellement de la
partie qui le plus le plus intéressant
peut-être vers la fin où je sais pas le
moment de lille cet article moi je pense
que ça si tu vends le 40e puisqu'il y
avait un léger détail note est bon ça
s'est joué à peu près par là que ça
s'est joué par le 40e avoir peut-être on
va on va arriver à cette position alors
nous arrêter vous arrêtez louage sinclar
et zilina mardi à 5 s'étaient tendues
oui ça sert à ça ça rien le meilleur
coup je pense qu'il faut revenir avec le
cavalier en abscisses et on peut voir
que robert pouvait prendre le cavalier
en h4 aime faire des pions en double et
oui mais dans ce cas là il aurait eu
quelques quelques faiblesses sur son
propre rock à savoir que le pion angers
6 et des cases noires sont faibles oui
et donc c'était pas très pas très gênant
je craignais pas vraiment vous proche
d'accord du coup peut-être voulait se
servir de ce option après pour attaquer
poids même l'europe et demi oui 4 h 58
pour attaquer les revoilà éventuellement
aussi la colonne jay par un rush 1
étrangères d'accord pas peur de cette de
cet échange donc h scène qui a priori
pas utile à peut-être éloigné paix
continue on va essayer d'aller vite
parce que vraiment on a eu un peu de
minutes pour essayer de commenter les
moments intéressants de cette partie on
va essayer d'arriver vers le ver le 40e
coup premier peut-être premier passage
vers ce 40e ou peut on faire un deuxième
passage autour de 70 ans et sa wii voire
un peu voilà donc en suisse donc c'est
une partie on va commenter de façon
générale on va pas rentrer dans le
détail peut-être là mais où on a
l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup de
louvoiement c'est à dire qu'il ya des
roches à scander pièce on a vu le
cavalier partient est celui qui revient
le 6 donc on cherche la meilleure place
pour les billets c'est ça d'ailleurs je
pensais que c'était y aller j'ai proposé
à près de tournai 1 à christian j'ai
proposé la création mais il voulait pas
la première ronde ils les battent oui
mais voilà même si j'ai des bugs
particulièrement satisfait de la
tournure des événements ici à la place
de fous ces sept à mon avis je dois
changer les fous par cavalier 17
d'accord mais il est à mon avis s'attend
vraiment vers l'annuel maintenant
d'accord pour essayer d'échanger le fou
h4 avec le malin d'accord mais
effectivement c'est difficile mm
d'imaginer que les blancs puisse faire
des menaces puisque l'option détroit et
arriérée et si on échange des fois on va
jouer après prononcé cinq et on n'a plus
grand chose à défendre côté noir en tout
cas en tout cas ça a l'air assez
tranquille tranquille pour les noirs
tout le monde est à temps alors l'envié
on continue donc poussé cette voie la b4
et à 6 c je pense que c'est vraiment une
erreur j'avais fini toutes les dames
avec ce coup et christian va trouver
il va me fixer en fait sur cases noires
ce qui va être très désagréable par la
suite donc là c'est alors par contre à 5
c'est intéressant parce que c'est un
plan passé pour les noirs raisin oui
mais c'est peut-être une erreur je pense
qu'ils en pensent christian peut-être je
pense qu'il fallait plutôt prendre mes 5
parce que oui en fait le pion le pion à
5 et fait un peu peur comme ça parce
qu'il est passé protéger mais comme il
va être bloquée
rapidement il n'est pas il ne constitue
pas vraiment une menace on est donc
simplifier la position par pyongyang le
5 avril et prendre les cinq étaient
peut-être meilleur d'accord et on aurait
aussi aimé l'an passé en plus toujours
en bêtise vous pourrez fils donc là
c'est un choix un choix important
puisque on décide d'arriver dans enfin
de donner un fou contre un cavalier ça
change radicalement le en tout cas le
combat qui était en train de se dérouler
puisque la le matériel les plus
équilibrés et je pense que les blancs
jouent clairement contre le mauvais fond
c'est 7 qui est bloqué par ses propres
pions donc en fait on a deux cavaliers
contre cavaliers et mauvais foot
donc petit avantage blanc c'est ça sert
que les pions blancs sont quasi sûrs
sont pleins sont placés sur cases
blanches c'est ça c'est surtout le oui
enfin plutôt dans l'autre sens les pions
noirs sont sur 15 mois en avant ce qui
limite le foot recasement d'accord donc
cavalier shaker le g7 mais on va quand
même prendre le pouls pas sur un
cavalier c7 jeu reprend et j'attaque le
pion mais cinq d'accord donc s'effacer
pas envisageable bon c'était possible
mais chaud chaud et voire mieux quand
même pour les non donc là les noirs
continuent
le problème c'est que le coéfficient
soit là ça permet toujours un pion sur
15 mois
voilà là on voit que le fou des huit
parisiens complètement dominé par le
cahier des cinq contrôles les cas on
voit que à 5 c'était vraiment pas utile
du tout mais par contre robert avait un
choix s'était joué cavalier c7 d'accord
pour échanger lecavalier des cinq qui
est très fort et après essayer de me
mettre en valeur le pion 1 pacy d'accord
pour faire diversion donc à essayer de 3
et 4 l'accord dont christine bardi
lahoud alors on a vu une partie plus
violente avec une attaque contre le roi
là c'est le type de parti qu'il faut
aussi commander parce que il ya beaucoup
de partis aussi de ce style là qu'ils
rentraient dans une finale assez vite
finalement une position plus ou moins
symétrique
donc c'est vraiment la vision à long
terme et les plans à long terme de
placement de pièces qui sont importants
oui c'est une partie a tourné en plus
stratégique que celle de que jean marc
et laurent ont joué d'accord donc alors
peut-être les lois tu peux continuer on
peut voir avancer la suite en est on à
quels coûts là est-ce qu'on peut ce
qu'on peut savoir à peu près oui on
était de savoir on est au 37e coup est
donc ici ça a commencé en interrogeant
la 40e coup fatidique on l'a dit donc là
il reste peu de temps aux deux joueurs
c'est ça toujours pareil ce ya le zag
note du reste peu de temps pour enrayer
la natation il arrive il ya ma position
qui se dégradent petit à petit et le 40e
en plus donc ça commence vraiment à
faire beaucoup
alors là les blancs vont peut-être
augmenter la pression sur le plan des
six avec le cavalier qui peut les sur la
case c4 c'est ça il vaut les cavaliers
qui l'attaquent bêtise effectivement
c'est ce que j'ai joués qui avait laissé
quatre ans et donc robert avec de chemin
en fait la jouer cavalier à 4 qu'il a
fait je pense que c'est moi mais choisit
ce qui est une erreur c'est une erreur
pourquoi ces cavaliers protège b6
finalement mais il a tapé a blessé sa
part le roi en fait ils déjà ils
bloquent le pion passé et ensuite
ensuite il va être rivella pour le reste
de la partie parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'autre moyen de protéger le pion
d'utiliser en variante d'ailleurs qui
sont très risqué pour moi puisque quand
christian jours à f4 ça va libérer la
case des 4 es mon cavalier n'aura plus
qu'à c'est à dire que dès qu'il sera
attaqué par le roi moncava y en a 4 sera
piégé donc si tu avais pas vu dans la
précipitation du nord
donc on va voir longue la suite des
coups droits b3 attaque le quart il ya 4
puis 6 une imprécision aussi ça revient
on revient maintenant c'était pour
répéter du coup pas s'il aurait pu
jusqu'à 17 à ce moment là voilà encore
oui mais comme il est resté dans son
erreur c'est ça il est revenu sur
l'accord donc ça c'est dommage parce que
oui mais pas en saignant qu'on se rend
pas compte de l'accord de ces choses à
quoi donc la roi aux 6 et ensuite la f4
donc ça c'est un coup part ça c'est
important dans cette supposition c'est
trop tard il faut essayer de créer une
tension une rupture une ouverture oui
sur un second front
et donc là en fait l'idée c'était de
dévier le pion au sein comme l'a dit
robert
donc je puisse moi même joué des trois
des quatre ans devant la dernière case
aux cavaliers dalmate la saison est donc
ici j'ai réfléchi très longtemps pourra
essayer de m'imposer g5 pour jouer f5
essayer de déstabiliser un peu christian
de donner le pion aux 5 et d'avoir un
peu de jeu pour mon fond des huit qui
vraiment ridicule pour l'instant donc
mais ça marche pas malheureusement donc
après g5 je suis réduit à la défense
au total donc f5 échec groix en 17
donc là on peut voir aussi que j'ai eu
l'occasion mais traitement parlant les
viandes blanches sont vraiment bien
placé hors cadre d'un chai bloc et pour
noircir leurs cases noires le food
évident ne sert à rien enfin protéger
ses pions en service il ne peut pas
avoir un rôle actif
alors là il ya une triangulation ce qui
fait qu'on a fait on a donné le très
haut noire les noirs qui n'ont pas
vraiment de coup dans cette position
puisque le fou des huit défend les
d'options donc ne peut pas bouger et les
blancs en fait force le roi noir a
reculé sur la case 1,8 ou s'est vite
puisque ce recueil c5 évidemment je
pense comprendre et pion b6 donc on peut
revoir la manoeuvre peut-être voilà
c'était comme ça le roi est en c2
bonjour wab et 3,7 au plan de jouer qu'à
et ses cinq échecs
rocé 3 il faut revenir pour défendre
l'option b 6 donc cavalier à quatre
échecs roi ces deux on est dans la même
position sauf que c'est au noir de jouer
donc on a gagné du terrain avec les
blancs puisque le roi noir doit partir
voilà faut jouer le roi le roi va assez
vite alors qu'avec des six alors c'est
quoi l'idée ce cavalier va essayer
d'attaquer des pertes de l'autre côté
c'est oui et puis si on ne sait changer
contre le fou des huit qui protège le
pion m6 qui ne les a pas de tension
dispense de retombe il ya le seul plan b
6 7 9 6 qui va tomber
voilà ce qui m'embête c'est ce
qu'avaient les dessins qui vraiment
domina position exactement
donc si c'est dur de jouer robert une
position comme ça de défense darpa ce
qu'on peut devenir ce type de position
je pense pas parce que les blancs donc
une chance de perdre donc il peut
travailler la position pendant
un temps assez long et moi je peux rien
faire donc
à long terme je pense que ça va perdre
de toute manière donc comme tu faisais
partie à ce moment là tu penses que tu
vas perdre les routes
oui je suis sûr pourquoi tu continues et
pour avoir quand même s'il s'en sort
quand même c'est facile trop oui mais
christian us et il a ses forces et ses
positions moi je continue quand même
pour voir sa manoeuvre de gains parce
qu'à ce moment là c'est pas c'est pas si
clair que ça a déjà restauré mais un
espoir nous voilà j'aurai cette position
est d'accord mais bon c'est un peu plus
par parnac quoi d'accord donc on cherche
on cherche arnaque
mais ici c'est fini maintenant puisqu'il
va attaquer le plus 1,6 avec ses deux
cavaliers et on voit que j'ai pas
s'améliorer d'accord voilà seulement
voilà ça va être dur on peut paris le
roi des forêts que le roi repasse par au
8 ème set c'est ça voilà c'est compliqué
grâce à faire de fausses ailes en créant
un temps voilà donc la cavalier g8 et
l'assaillant voix près +16 va tomber
donc h 4 contres en h4 et après voilà ça
lui l'option existence donc là c'est
toute la structure des noirs content
parce que maintenant le pion aux 5es
faibles tout à fait des caves six tombes
tout ont donc donc là c'est dur en est
donc là et encore quelques coups donc en
fait mais là là là tu es conscient que
ça va être bien oui il joue
oui d'ailleurs robert jeu mais très vite
cette maman d'un pin creux n'est plus
d'accord donc c'est une victoire
finalement ce qu'on a nos échecs on
masse l'adversaire j'aurais préféré
gagner plus de 60 plus spectaculaire
mais bon comme robert s'est très bien
défendu au début
je n'ai pas trop le choix d'accord donc
là c'est fini on arrive à la position
finale
eloi peut-être oui non c'est fini c'est
fini donc c'est la pression finale ça
oui
donc là donc alors comment on peut
résumer cette partie alors ça c'est
intéressant parce qu'on a eu 2 2
oppositions de style d'un mètre de
partie et dont on n'a pas le temps de
commenter une partie aussi longue mais
ça ça arrive souvent c'est parti il faut
gagner
souvent on arrache niveau-là de jeu à
l'arraché cl c'est pas évident de gagner
des points si on va pas jusqu'au bout
donc comment comment ça s'est passé
comment se passe ce type de parti dans
l'espoir de gains du joueur bel âge et
surtout bénéficié du manque de temps
d'un robert je pense parce que s'il
avait plus de temps ils n'auraient
trouvé qu'elle valait 17 au lieu de
cavalia 4 d'accord et à ce moment là il
fallait tout refaire et c'était
peut-être déjà déjà nul d'accord donc la
pression du temps à décider sûrement de
la partie donc ces importantes gérait
bien son temps aux échecs oui ça c'est
sûr d'accord robert aussi tu penses que
c'était le moment clé finalement le ski
a décidé à participer plus que la
position si le manque de temps oui tout
à fait s'il femme et j'ai vraiment très
lentement devant le début parce que ce
qu'elle joue et s'était complètement
atypique et je connaissais pas du tout
donc j'ai dû prendre beaucoup de temps
pour retrouver un plan un bon placement
pour mes pièces et ont gelé payer par la
suite quoi d'accord donc c'était alors
ensuite bon on a vu cette partie
peut-être vous pouvez vous nous raconter
votre votre tournoi commence à s'est
déroulée pour les pour les partitions
dans peut-être christian ça s'est bien
passé
sa multi puisque tu en tête actuellement
donc tu vas rejoindre la poule haute et
avec 5 points à égalité donc avec arnaud
hauchard café aussi un excellent début
de tournoi et
comment ça s'est passé c'est ce début
j'en sais bien partit donc avec cette
victoire
oui donc le tournoi s'est plutôt bien
passé jusque là pendant mais comme je
l'avais dit au début les parties que
j'ai gagné j'ai dû travailler dur contre
guillot valence était égal pendant
quarante coups à peu près avant qui
fassions des rares et contre manuel a
pissé là pendant très longtemps aussi
plus plus de trente coups c'était
équilibré et avant qu'il fasse aussi des
des imprécisions
donc ça c'est quand même pas mal pas mal
déroulés il ya pas eu de grosse frayeur
pendant ce premier vol oui et non enfin
contre contre leurs contrats signés
contre weiser c'était des choses c'était
délicat d'accord et pour toi robert
après cette défaite c'est pas évident de
voir avec une défaite c'est sur un
championnat ça c'est vrai pour tous les
sports vous foot aussi au tennis aussi
mais d'ailleurs j'ai fait dix ans et
même éliminé d'ailleurs mais je la salue
on peut jouer quand même oui donc ce
pour ce gène chez suivi par autre nul
donc j'essaie de j'essayais de plus
perdre et gagner c'est pas facile contre
contre des gars comme ça ensuite j'ai
encore perdu contre genre un décor au
bout encore de 7 heures de jeu donc un
peu comme en construction et j'ai
terminé par un nul et une victoire
finalement donc bon g - 1 par rapport à
la moyenne
donc c'est pas terrible mais bon j'ai
pas beaucoup perdu ça aurait pu être
pire après la première ronde quoi et
j'ai il j'aurais pu quand même à voir
j'ai eu des positions gagnantes que j'ai
pas concrétisées donc bon tant pis voilà
bon on a un peu les deux extrêmes donc
des difficultés pour robert mais ces
bébés aussi tu as ta va venir devant toi
christian est un peu plus âgé ok -
avenir devant lui mais il y en a plus y
en a quand même un très beau puisque
donc déjà les
la poule haute qui dessine donc avec un
très bon très bon avantage au départ
c'est un point avec l'égalité avec
arnaud donc on a sûrement l'occasion de
revoir christian dans la suite de ces
événements donc on vous rappelle qu'on
est là donc jusqu'à la fin de ce tournoi
donc 70 soit dimanche éventuellement cas
d'égalité il y aura des masses de
départage donc tous les soirs rendez
vous à 21h sur des bonal avec donc les
champions analyse des partis et
résultats complets donc moi je vous
donne rendez vous pour la suite donc
bravo christian pour se répandre et du
tournoi et puis à bientôt donc on espère
3 voir sur le plateau dans les jours
prochains et robert aussi donc bonne
suite c'est important aussi c'est poule
basse il faut faire un bon résultat pour
pas faut avoir une place honorable à la
foire une place honorable s'il ya quand
même des choses à gagner c'est de
l'argent bien peu d'argent gagné voilà
donc je vous donne congé merci à vous
d'être d'être passé moi je vous dis donc
à demain 21h sur diagonale pour voir la
suite de de ce tournoi je sais pas si on
peut envoyer le le générique en avant et
donc